sept ans cette année maintenant que le
drapeau russe flotte au dessus de la
crimée en mars 2014 alors que l'ukraine
était confronté à de graves troubles
les habitants de crime et ont exprimé le
souhait de voir leur région rattachée à
la fédération de russie et le ministre
des affaires étrangères russe qui s'est
exprimé à l'occasion de cette date
anniversaire a tenu à être clair il n'y
aura pas de retour en arrière
ce bobo de cheveux sort et l'avenir de
la crimée sont à jamais lié à la russie
que cela plaise ou non
aucune démarche des états occidentaux
menée par les états unis d'amérique ne
peut changer cette réalité que ce soit
du point de vue du droit international
ou d'un point de vue politique ou morale
se son côté notre diplomatie continuera
à travailler vigoureusement afin
d'enraciner dans l'esprit des
partenaires étrangers
les réalités liées au retour de la
péninsule dans le giron de la patrie
les autorités ukrainiennes de leur côté
ne l'entendent pas de cette oreille
leur président a préparé une stratégie
pour mettre fin à ce qu'ils considèrent
être l'occupation d'une région on
craignait il ya sept ans la russie a
tenu un faux référendum au crime et pour
la première fois depuis le début de
l'occupation
l'ukraine a préparé une stratégie de
désoccupation et de réintégration de la
péninsule
nous appelons le monde à s'unir au sein
de la plate forme pour la crimée pour
rattacher ce qui est ukrainien à
l'ukraine en cette année
la russie a beaucoup fait pour
développer les infrastructures de la
crimée des infrastructures jusque là
délaissés et le symbole du développement
de cette région est bien entendu le port
de crimée qui relie dorénavant la
presqu'île à la russie continental par
la route et par le rail la population
elle paraît apprécier tous ses efforts
et semble ne pas regretter son choix
comme l'ont d'ailleurs souligné
plusieurs sondages
beaucoup de choses ont été construites
si on parle du domaine social
suffisamment par exemple désormais dans
la cour voisine
il y a enfin des installations pour
enfants une petite bourde est l'état
nation
mais bien sûr notre grande fierté et le
conte de crimée et la route aux rides
mois qu'il ya beaucoup d'endroits et
c'est également la route pour sébastopol
par exemple me donner une heure et demie
désormais c'est beaucoup plus rapide et
je trouve donc que les choses ne fait
que s'améliorer
non mon commentaire je préfère le
travail que j'ai maintenant je gagne
plus désormais quand on faisait partie
de l'ukraine qu'il n'y avait pas de
perspective
il y en a beaucoup plus je suis content
de ce qui s'est passé il ya 700 j'ai moi
même par triompher au référendum tout
s'est bien passé
personne ne m'a menacé avec une arme des
amis à moi de zappos ory ont demandé si
c'était vrai qu'on nous menacé avec des
armes
je leur ai expliqué que c'était
n'importe quoi tout s'est fait de
manière honnête je les ai vues de mes
propres yeux le reste je n'y crois pas
tout simplement
alors bien sûr ce différend territorial
entre l'ukraine et la russie n'est pas
sans conséquence par exemple pour
l'alimentation en eau de la péninsule du
temps de l'urss un canal avait été
construit depuis le fleuve dniepr en
ukraine pour ravitailler la crimée en
eau potable
mais depuis 2014 kiev a fermé le robinet
occasionnant des pénuries récurrentes ce
qui entraîne aussi de graves
conséquences sur l'agriculture locale
fortement dépendante de l'irrigation
cette situation entre les deux pays a
également généré une hausse des tensions
en mer noire
fin novembre 2018 un incident a même eu
lieu entre les marines russe et
ukrainienne avec la capture de trois
navires ukrainien et l'emprisonnement de
24 marins détention qui ne risque pas de
s'atténuer
le pentagone annoncé une aide militaire
de 125 millions de dollars à l'ukraine
principalement sous la forme de deux
navires patrouilleurs depuis sept ans
que la crimée a rejoint la russie les
habitants de cette région ont observé
une amélioration des infrastructures
ainsi que de leurs conditions de vie
mais la situation géopolitique de cette
région d'europe est très instable entre
le conflit larvé dans le donbass et la
militarisation croissante en mer noire